very quickly i'm just going to say if my
voice sounds a little bit under the
weather that's because i've had coveted
for the last week but that ain't
stopping me from talking about house of
the dragon episode 1 and i won't go into
any major spoilers right away to me the
show is pretty good but it isn't as
great yet as game of thrones i know you
probably hear that from a lot of other
people but to me most of the dialogue
thus far genuinely didn't wow me from
how much of it there was two standout
lines were damon targaryen calling the
small council a council of leeches and
viserys targaryen calling the iron
throne the most dangerous seat in
westeros that line was unexpectedly kind
of funny given that it has a double
meaning from the literal sense that it's
physically hurting him and the
figurative meaning that everyone's
fighting to sit in it but so far there
hasn't been any banger lines that are
immediately quotable like in game of
thrones it's primarily the new writers
are a lot more competent and consistent
at writing than david and dan like it
feels like a miracle to witness almost
an hour of dialogue without being bored
out of my mind from how bad the dialogue
is moving a bit more chronologically
through the episode hbo is clearly
flaunting their champion purse with all
their expensive wide shots with tons of
vfx it's really nice to see a bigger
budget on display here but in a sense i
kind of miss the smaller and grounded
scale and more realistic look of season
1 of game of thrones because even the
cinematography is a lot more dramatic
with a harsher contrast meanwhile most
of the cinematography in season one of
game of thrones it felt a lot more
naturalistic and less moody aiding more
to the realism but these are essentially
different styles that work both in their
own right going back to some
introductory scenes i bet i wasn't the
only person who got a little upset when
we saw some of the past sets in the red
keep like it made me kind of depressed
when i was reminded where this was where
jamie and cersei were about to get
smushed by bricks moving on though since
that's kind of just me nitpicking the
introductions for the characters
relationships and the general
backgrounds felt inconsistent like the
opening of the show starts with
immediate narration which in of itself
was a bit of a shock since game of
thrones never utilized that since it
kind of breaks that realism with
non-diegetic sound but i can definitely
excuse it here since it's really hard to
communicate where we are in the history
of game of thrones however my main gripe
with the introductions and house of the
dragon comes from the fact that the
creators essentially throw us into the
deep end by starting with a small
council meeting now for people who
already know who these characters are
like myself that wasn't really an issue
but this is westeros there are hundreds
of characters and casual viewers will be
having a hard time understanding who is
who the creators did a great job in
setting up relationships like the feud
between otto hightower and damon
targaryen but there's still a lot that
wasn't introduced a natural comparison
to draw from would be the first episode
of game of thrones through robert
barathen coming to winterfell our pov
characters along with the audience are
learning who these people are but in
house of the dragon we don't really get
that luxury we only briefly hear each
character's name once or twice at the
end of the day this isn't a major issue
but i asked my friends who watched the
premiere with me if they knew most of
the people who weren't targaryens by the
end of the episode and they had a lot of
trouble identifying them house of the
dragon though does a good job in
developing their key players early on
characters like viserys daemon renera
allison hightower and otto hightower all
get strong character development and we
quickly know the relationships between
all of them that's definitely a strength
the episode has it's just most of the
sad characters can fall by the wayside
without much acknowledgement so when
they do get acknowledged you are
immediately confused as to who they are
and why they matter i'm assuming this
won't persist as an issue given that
through the episodes we'll get more
development for them it's just a little
weird the writers didn't come up with a
natural way to introduce us to everyone
looking at renera there's a specific
moment in the very beginning where she's
on our dragon in which the music clearly
plays daenerys's theme with a little bit
of changes now this got me a little
worried because firstly i don't want
them to reuse a lot of themes from game
of thrones and secondly they seem to be
trying really hard to mold ronira after
daenerys and that was made really
apparent when they use her theme with a
slight alteration when she was on her
own dragon i want her to stand out on
her own more because the creator seemed
to be obsessed with dany given that even
in the opening sequence of titles they
mention her i know it's kind of hard to
not make her similar to daenerys since
renera is also breaking the wheel in her
own way but you need to differentiate a
bit more and it's nice that we get a lot
of down-to-earth scenes with her and
allison to help with that then we have
daemon targaryen which matt smith so far
is doing a great job it's just a tad bit
awkward to see him balls deep in a woman
after watching him for years and doctor
who but that's just me left a bit of a
weird off-putting feeling in my mouth
but for other fans maybe it's what
they've always dreamed of in terms of
damon as a character though i hope the
writers try to paint him more as the
protagonist in future episodes because
right now it feels like he's a
straight-up antagonist because it feels
like the writers did damon dirty by
immediately having him execute and maim
a bunch of criminals which criminals i
might add that weren't even shown as
being criminals it came across as damon
terrorizing the locals and is a menace
to society i like his more tender
relationship with ronira given that it
at least showcases some of his good side
i hope the writers make this like a
civil war scenario in which both sides
are right and justified it just depends
on their perspective but i hope they
don't lean too heavily on him being a
flat out bad guy and this turns into a
black and white conflict because the
second you go that route the conflict
becomes more stale for visser targaryen
i want to talk about the best scene
which was to me the birth scene the
choice he has to make and the entire
conflict of that scene was staggering
and with some excellent writing on top
of the fact that this was all intercut
with a jousting tournament and this was
by far the peak of the episode if they
can deliver scenes like this
consistently then i think they can match
game of thrones from an emotional
standpoint and a dramatic standpoint and
going back to the jousting tournament
the budget here is on great display most
of the time the shot of damon targaryen
sliding on the bar as he falls off his
horse was stunning and it seems like
they even paid homage to over martel
getting his head smashed open the only
thing that bothered me in this scene
which i doubt was a budgetary issue and
is probably more stylistic which was the
excessive cutting during the fight
between damon targaryen and sir kirsten
cole because surely if the budget was
big enough they'd be able to afford
longer takes or it could be miguel
sapochnick because in the past he has
shown that he likes his action to be a
bit more chaotic by cutting more
frequently and every now and then he'll
throw in a longer take to give the
audience a break from the relentlessness
of the edits i hope this doesn't
continue in later action scenes because
i want it to be more coherent and this
could be a limitation from the people
being in heavy armor so that could be
the reason for shorter takes the overall
jousting tournament though besides that
one moment was very good and the
practical stunts were extremely
impressive again the higher budget is
working wonders then for one other
character i want to talk about before
going into the ending we have otto
hightower although he didn't get as much
screen time as other characters reese
stefan who plays the character was
entrancing he feels like he perfectly
fits into the dna of game of thrones
like a corrupt little finger that is
more powerful and hardens in almost
every shot the actor shows so many
subtleties to be picked up on and so far
i can't take my eyes off him he
essentially feels like a mix of tywin
and littlefinger which seems like an
absolute dream come true then for the
ending i won't go into major spoilers
but there's a development they set up
that impacts targaryens as a whole and
connects back to the song of ice and
fire which the development makes sense
but it feels like it only exists to make
vernier seem even more like the lead
protagonist i wasn't able to get through
the book since it was primarily just a
macer talking about past events so i
don't know if this was a change that was
made because it feels like it is and i
can be wrong anyways i'd give the
introductory episode about a 7 to an 8.
thank you for watching and let me know
your thoughts on the first episode of
house of the dragon